this is zhu
and like most three-year-olds he likes
nothing better than a trip to a toy shop
but how can his parents be sure that a
toy that might catch his eye is safe
hello
can separate
while all the toys in this store are
high quality and meet strict eu
standards that's not the story
everywhere
since 2009 the toy safety directive has
made toys sold in the eu safer
but with the rise of online sales
especially from outside the eu many toys
and products for children don't always
meet those standards
new toxic chemicals are a challenge as
is the growth of toys connected to the
internet which pose dangers to
children's privacy hacking is a major
concern
toy safety rules need to be updated
because things are changing we have
connected toys we have different
challenges related to substances we need
to be sure that
toy safety rules are in line with the
new safety requirements in a changing
world
new risks are constantly emerging
mep say the rules must be better
designed to adapt to advances in science
and technology they also want stricter
limits on toxic and cancer-causing
chemicals
on top of these changes all toy safety
rules should be better enforced in
member states